hey guys it's pete peppers from candy
crush saga saga tips com and from the
candy crush saga saga tips & Friends
group on Facebook want to make a quick
video to show you all the different
features that we have in the group and
some things you might not have noticed
figured if I made a video I'll at least
all you English speakers would be able
to watch it real quick and get a good
idea of how things you know what you
might be missing in here in general i
guess so first of all you can see the
group's growing growing it to wherever
sixteen thousand members right now and
it seems to just continue to grow at the
top we have a pin post and it tells you
some quick and simple rules to get the
most out of posting in the group and one
of the things that says is too if you
want to add get friends you just we have
a special post where we keep our abney
request which you can go to by clicking
here and you can put it then your
comments with all the other ones this
has 1700 on the list only it's actually
been bigger than that we just have to
take people off every once in a while to
reset the notifications for this post so
all you do is you come here you write
your name tell them to add you add my
name again because I'm obviously a lot
of people sign up every day and I want
to I always accept everyone's friends
request so I'll put anyone at the bottom
and now that I've done that anyone that
comes here can add me they can just
click on my thing and we can add other
people too I'll send a friend request
like their posts to note so that they'll
know you can also send the message if
you want to let them know that you're at
an amendment
and that's how the at me works now the
Evie post it's sort of this sort of just
floats in the in the and the feed since
I just made a comment on it it's not at
the top you can see but as other people
bump things up it will fall down so
that's how that works we also have a
list of files here that are real helpful
this is tells you when you first get
here what to do these are the roles in
case you were wondering and then we have
our list of helpful links which can be
really cool and the other thing we have
is the search feature up here so if
you're looking for what other players
upset about a level you can just write
the level number in hit enter and it
will give you these different all the
different things and you can click on
these to see what it was so here there's
a video posted you got some different
comments there and then like in this
case there's tips so this was posted
about five days ago but we have tips in
there so you know you can find lots of
different things if you're if you're
going to look around so I'm going to go
back to the files real quick this group
was started by me and it could you know
most a lot of week I've had a few other
big groups on facebook and I make videos
and write tips as you probably know so
here is our useful links and one of the
things that week you know I keep the
group available I try to keep everybody
getting their answers and everything
like that and what I hope is that you'll
support my content rather than just
going into google and you know searching
for anybody or things like that you know
we have a community
um you know I try my best to make the
most useful tips and keep things up to
date as possible so I just hope that you
know you guys will use use my stuff you
know subscribe to my channel bookmark my
site so that you'll know where you're
going to find something so real quick
I'm going to click on a few of these and
show you what they are this is the how
to play section of my website and you
can see that we have a long post about
what's different and you know what
what's the deals Otesaga compared to the
original there's a video here that's got
commentary where I explain the basic
functions and then you also have guys to
the level types God's the special candy
and the level guides so anything you
want to know about how this game works
you can find an article and most likely
a video to go along with it another
useful link and that you know that this
is where we get most of our links that
we post for you when you ask for help
it's here this is the level guides and
you can see that we have a complete
level index they're all listed below so
if you need content if you need a video
if you need tips you know you can find
it right here so this is a tab system so
like say we wondered the level you know
what 198 video it's right there if we
wanted to 45 it's right there and so on
and so forth so you know that's
something that you know if we're not
around or if you just want to if you you
know if you'd rather not wait for a
response even though we're pretty quick
you can always get anything that you
need for this here and the last thing is
if you don't want to you just want
videos or you just want to be able to
you know see what we have for other
games and stuff like that then you come
to our YouTube channel and I hope that
you would subscribe
um you know like the videos and share
because it's very communal hard to get a
good ranking on youtube and then your
support really helps in that level but
you can see that a search function here
if you need to take their level you can
just type it in you know so the level 1
30 or whatever you can find all the
videos that I upload here for let's say
see the different games and things then
we have the videos also in playlist so
you can come through and find you know
with that you know that's just if you
prefer it prefer YouTube over the web
pages so that's that's about it just
wanted to point out that you know this
our group we you know we really try to
make it completely you know complete
complete to so that you know you can
find everything that you need and if you
ever have questions just ask as you can
see here if you need up at the level or
how something works make a new post in
the feed don't comment in someone else's
post and that's um that's it there's a
simple reason behind that and that is is
that when I look up here whenever I'm a
monitor my group this group and the
other groups and stuff is I don't see
that there's a new post in the group and
let someone make some new post if you
just comment on somebody else's then
there's no guarantee that we'll see it
so let me delete this fam real quick and
thank you for watching this if you have
any questions like I said let us know
and we'll be glad to make do our best to
get you whatever help you need alright
thanks